Donald Trump has wrongly accused former
President Barack Obama of releasing
quote 122 vicious prisoners from
Guantanamo Bay he recently tweeted 122
vicious prisoners released by the Obama
administration from Gitmo have returned
to the battlefield just another terrible
decision exclamation point once again
Donald Trump is getting his news from
Fox News but he's misunderstanding the
reports of Fox News Donald Trump posted
this tweet Tuesday morning two days ago
while Fox & Friends was talking about no
other topic then Guantanamo detainee
Yasir al Cilmi being killed in Yemen by
an American airstrike and the segment
ended by saying quote a hundred and
twenty two prisoners released from Gitmo
have returned to the battlefield now
that didn't mention which President saw
or oversaw those Gitmo detainees
released donald trump saw that and
assumed that the report was referring to
released by obama but it turns out that
of the hundred and twenty-two detainees
released 113 were released by none other
than our buddy george w bush president
obama only released nine of them
watching fox news is getting trump into
trouble and it's so funny because of the
timing pat there's no doubt what it is
that Donald Trump is doing Fox News does
a story about 122 Gitmo detainees and
minutes later Donald Trump is tweeting
based on his misunderstanding of that
story and the thing is I think he would
have been fine with criticizing george w
bush as well even though he's a fellow
republican because he's kind of wrapped
up the previous president says people
responsible for the american carnage
that's going on of course ocean trump
have had their back and forth to some
extent but i don't even think he
researched this before tweeting it out
because he doesn't know how to research
right i mean of course he didn't i like
a pat naively says i you know david it's
possible that donald trump made may not
have researched what happened of course
he didn't research it and watching fox
news gets trump in trouble pretty
regularly just weeks ago trump was
watching fox news report
about crime in Sweden misinterpreted it
and then like the next day went to a
rally and said did you see what happened
in Sweden last night for as nothing
happened in Sweden what can we learn
from this number one Donald Trump
doesn't know that much about the most
high-profile military prison that we
have that's number one number two Donald
Trump is getting information about
important issues from Fox News and
responding in almost real-time and
number three Donald Trump is not
actually understanding what's being said
on Fox News Fox News is meant to
communicate with a little homophobic let
me rephrase before I say something
offensive Fox News communicates in
relatively simple language and the fact
that Donald Trump is consistently
misunderstanding what Fox News is saying
is both sad exclamation point and
low-energy
exclamation point agree disagree I agree
I mean the thing is when you watch six
hours of television each day I think
your mind can kind of start to turn to
mush yeah so maybe he can't even
understand that the theme of the week
has been for president Trump this week
blame Obama for anything you can think
of because this Russia stuff is getting
a little bit too hot for my liking in
this case just as with Obama wiretapped
me Trump took stories from conservative
or right-wing or propaganda media and
then added his own lies on top right
same thing as Obama wiretapped me it
started with conservative right-wing
commentary and then Trump added his lies
to that in this case 122 former Gitmo
detainees released and Trump added to
that by former President Barack Obama
hard to stay on top of all the nonsense
these days and when you've got a
president that's responding in real-time
to Fox News we've got our work cut out
for us here Gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at Gamefly offer
dot-com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the David
Pakman show audience and support our
show by going to Gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s